[Music]
on this tuesday night feeling the heat
record high temperatures fueling fires
and causing travel troubles in europe
this is pretty extreme as humidity
cranks up the heat in parts of canada
the message from meteorologists disaster
and disbelief it's absolutely insane the
powerful storm that pummeled an alberta
community calls for a life-saving
solution the push for a three-digit
suicide crisis hotline
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jeff semple
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us scorching temperatures are sweeping
across the globe affecting millions of
people parts of central canada and the
prairies are now under heat warnings and
the mercury is even higher in europe
with record-breaking temperatures that
one french meteorologist is calling a
heat apocalypse
the uk shattered its hottest day on
record with temperatures there hitting
40.3 degrees celsius in a village north
of cambridge the german town of barrel
hit a sweltering 39.3 degrees marking
that country's hottest day of the year
and in france temperatures topped 40
degrees in paris the second hottest
temperature ever recorded in that city
here in north america more than 100
million people in the united states
faced heat-related warnings or
advisories today with temperatures
reaching 43 degrees celsius in dallas
and environment canada has issued heat
warnings for saskatchewan manitoba
ontario and quebec with very high
temperature or humidity conditions and
severe thunderstorms expected in the
coming days
we have comprehensive coverage of the
extreme weather our reporters are in the
hot spots here in canada the united
states and in europe we'll have more on
the situation here at home in just a
moment but we begin in the uk our
redmond shannon is in london where the
city's fire brigade has now declared a
major incident after a surge of heat
fueled fires in the british capital
redmond
jeff firefighters remain at the scene
here and in many other locations across
southern england record-breaking
temperatures that turned many parts of
this country into tinder boxes
a neighborhood in flames on a day when
britain baked as temperatures topped 40
degrees in the uk for the first time on
record fires flared up across southern
england remarkably this blaze began
right beside a fire station but in these
conditions there was little the
firefighters could do to save some of
the houses
in the parched weather the mayor has
urged londoners not to light any
barbecues or fires for the next two days
this is not about us being in any state
or party poopers it's the reality of
accidents happening and fires starting
and spreading rapidly train travel has
been disrupted for a second day due to
fires and tracks buckling in the heat
about to change hotels this morning
because the trains were not running so
we've had to get another train
at least 29 locations in the uk
registered temperatures above the
previous record of 38.7
many of them above 40. even climate
change campaigners are surprised britain
reached this scorching milestone so soon
over the last two years in particular
we've seen so many
really disturbing weather events that
climate change the science of climate
change has been validated in the public
mind their hope is that events like this
will trigger stronger action on climate
it will not be
a tipping point if politicians don't
really react records didn't just fall in
england scotland broke its all-time
temperature record on tuesday too the
good news is that on wednesday
temperatures will drop considerably
remaining in the mid-20s here in london
jeff
redmond shannon in london thanks redmond
the intense heat is also fueling
hundreds of wildfires across europe at
least two people have been killed in
spain in blazes the prime minister is
blaming on climate change in france
wildfires have ravaged the southwestern
part of the country forcing thousands to
flee their homes and leaving some areas
in total ruins
firefighters in greece are scrambling to
maintain a wildfire north of athens
which is now said to be threatening
homes in a suburb of the greek capital
here at home heat warnings have been
issued across four provinces stretching
from central canada to the prairies now
we're not expecting to see temperatures
on the scale they're witnessing across
parts of europe but as mike drolet
explains officials are still urging
canadians to take precautions
these days the beach isn't just an
escape it's a reprieve from a humidity
fueled heat wave making ontario and
quebec feel like an oven and putting
paramedics on notice i think the biggest
thing that we tend to see is
an increase in calls related to that so
individuals who are calling in with heat
exhaustion heat stroke gauging the
temperature can be tricky for a lot of
people environment canada measures the
true air temperature by putting its
thermometers in the shade so while it
might feel like a high of 31 here and be
quite pleasant
when i go into the sun the true
temperature for me because of the direct
sunlight is probably closer to 40
degrees
and the message from meteorologists and
climate scientists get used to it this
year and every year so this is not
something foreign to us but it's getting
more frequent more intense longer
lasting occurring earlier and going
later and so we clearly see what the
future is the future is more of this i
was okay without an air conditioner
until about five years ago and then it
was like oh yeah
you need it like i can feel it getting
hotter and hotter every year adding to
ontario's woes right now a lack of
rainfall if that doesn't change soon
farmers warned the food chain could
suffer
corn stalks for one aren't as tall as
normal without moisture the kernels
won't develop on the cob what we could
end up with is just a green stalk or
possibly even just
a cob with a few kernels on it so it
will impact everything from
feed for livestock to feed food for
human consumption for jim clark and
margaret long the trend towards hotter
summers led to them prioritizing a dream
vacation that's why we're going to the
arts yeah because if we don't see it now
it's not going to be there anymore a hot
summer with slow burning implications
microlight global news toronto
southeastern alberta is reeling after a
fast-moving powerful storm swept through
that region yesterday
holy
take a look at this video a full-size
trampoline carried by the wind bent in
half around a light standard heavy rain
and strong winds pummeled that area
yesterday knocking out power and
destroying homes and vehicles in its
path
our dallas flex hog is in cypress county
tonight with more on how those
communities are coping dallas
jeff it's sunny now but the damage left
behind is proof that this storm packed a
powerful punch
a view from above shows what mother
nature can do in an instant over half a
dozen homes are wiped out by what
environment canada is calling a gust
front that packed 140 kilometer an hour
winds we just bought this one three
months ago
on the ground helmet dooring is left
surveying the damage of what used to be
a workshop filled with antique
studebaker cars it was a building yes
and now it's a pile of cars have you
ever seen anything like this only on tv
from the disasters down the states it
was just totally white with rain
helmet's son ed also had a close call
then i heard this crash look behind me
and there was this tree branch
that was sticking through my roof
what were you thinking
what do you think you think holy
hopefully i make it through this that's
all
so are six construction workers who took
shelter in this trailer before it was
tossed 30 meters and crushed amazingly
they all survived the trailer is
a mess i don't know how they walked out
of it
it's absolutely insane nobody was hurt
or is unaccounted for in this storm
although some livestock was lost
thousands throughout the county dealing
with downed trees and power outages
crews have been working around the clock
to restore
cypress county says it is still in
recovery mode serving just how much
damage was done it is absolutely a
tremendous
loss
and
it's a shock the biggest thing is that
there was no loss of human life
and
it's
we can rebuild
but we can't replace a person
so it is devastating
but we have to we sometimes have to
counter blessings too the county has
teamed up with the red cross offering
accommodations to those who can't go
home
and as the cleanup begins those here say
they will get through this as a
community
jeff
dalek flex hog in southeastern alberta
thanks dallas
this heat wave is also fueling calls for
action on climate change global warming
is making these extreme weather events
far more common the united states is one
of the largest emitters of greenhouse
gases and as jackson prescott reports
the american president is expected to
announce new measures aimed at the
climate crisis
dangerous heat is so widespread in the
u.s that nearly 100 local temperature
records have fallen so far this summer
we're certainly seeing more extreme
weather due to climate change yet in
steamy washington d.c it's clear the
american response to the climate crisis
is quickly wilting with much of
president biden's climate agenda blocked
by a senator from his own party joe
manchin from coal rich west virginia i
haven't walked away from anything
and inflation is my greatest concern add
to that a recent decision by the u.s
supreme court limiting emissions
regulations on power plants and
president biden's own visit to saudi
arabia where he pushed for more oil
production and one of the planet's
biggest emitters of greenhouse gases is
on a path to inaction there's no sugar
coating yet they are major setbacks in
recent polls 70 percent of americans
said climate change is a crisis more
than three quarters of the population
reports being personally affected by
extreme weather yet when it comes to the
top issues facing the country just 2
percent of americans mentioned climate
change
we absolutely should not be putting a
lot of action on climate change years
ago it was a problem for the future it
is a problem for now with no clear
political path forward president biden
is set to take executive action on
climate change and may eventually
declare a national climate emergency as
dozens of other countries have already
done
yet the president also risks having any
of his unilateral moves overturned by
the courts
that leaves the world's leading economy
on course to miss its once ambitious
emission reduction targets
a dangerous gamble for a planet in peril
jackson prosko global news washington
a day of thunderstorms and torrential
rain in new york city led to this
startling site a sinkhole opened up on a
street in the bronx growing rapidly to
swallow a parked van residents say this
is the second time a sinkhole has
appeared in the same spot the last one
took more than a year to repair
the prime minister calls it absolutely
unacceptable coming up how hockey canada
allegedly paid off sex abuse victims
there are damning new allegations hockey
canada kept a fund that could be used to
pay off sexual abuse victims
right now it's hard for anyone in canada
to have faith or trust in anyone
at hockey canada
what
we're learning today is absolutely
unacceptable
as first reported by the globe and mail
an affidavit from an ontario case
suggests the national body kept money in
a separate account to pay for uninsured
liabilities including potential claims
for historical sexual abuse this
multi-million dollar fund was financed
by player registration fees from across
the country last month the federal
government and corporate sponsors paused
funding to hockey canada following the
organization's settlement in an alleged
sexual assault case involving members of
canada's 2018 world junior team
in an emergency canadians can call 9-1-1
but pressure is mounting on ottawa to
establish a new three-digit hotline
specifically to help prevent suicides on
average about 10 canadians die every day
by suicide the house of commons voted in
favor of establishing a suicide
prevention hotline back in 2020 tonight
morgan campbell speaks to one survivor
who says the hotline is long overdue
30 years ago john kerens lost his arm
and leg when he was run over by a train
in a workplace accident incredibly he
survived and says he was given a second
chance at life i have been an individual
that had to kick my way out of that wet
paper bag
of
suicidals across canada people like
karen's are speaking out calling for the
establishment of a three-digit suicide
prevention crisis line that connects
people to mental health experts
reduction of the barrier between them
and getting help
can make a life-saving difference the
united states recently launched 988 a
three-digit national suicide prevention
hotline mental health experts want to
see something like it in canada i'm
really hoping that our government
continues to push for this consultations
between the federal government crtc and
mental health stakeholders are underway
at least 10 canadians die each day by
suicide and while it does not
discriminate data shows men boys and
indigenous youth are disproportionately
at risk how do we know that the very
people that are going to need it are
going to be able to have access to it
because there are probably still some
remote communities that don't even have
cellular service some critics argue
canada isn't meeting the mark when it
comes to suicide prevention as we still
lack a national suicide prevention
strategy we need a strategy that's
backed by
actual timelines and real funds so that
strategy is sorely lacking in canada
there are people out there like karen's
who dedicate their second chance to
helping others but a three-digit hotline
would be another tool to help one
available 24 hours a day little did i
know the sign that said dead end on the
other side it said just the beginning
morgan campbell global news coburg
ontario
and if you or someone you know needs
help you can call talk suicide canada at
wait times and 1-833-456-4566 delays may
now face another travel hurdle random
covid 19 testing measures returned to
four major airports today the federal
policy is back in effect for
international arrivals at montreal
toronto calgary and vancouver airports
the testing requirements were paused
back in june those selected will now be
tested at an off-site facility and if
found positive they must isolate for 10
days
political pipeline pressure ahead will
russia cut off europe's critical energy
supplies
welcome back western european nations
are now scrambling to make contingency
plans with uncertainty clouding the
future of one of their largest sources
of energy the nordstream one pipeline is
expected to go back online this week
after a brief outage for annual
maintenance but as abigail beeman
reports it's not clear if russia will
agree to restart the flow of gas
european governments are planning for
all energy possibilities what we're
watching is a game of political chicken
between the russians and the eu
with germany being on the sharp end
tuesday morning reuters reported
state-owned gazprom will allow at least
some gas to flow thursday after
maintenance is completed work that
required canada to bend sanctions and
allow turbine parts repaired in montreal
to be returned a controversial move
where did the prime minister's office
where did the cabinet
see a win for canada in all of this
there's there's some
explanations or some suggestions that a
candidate did this to ensure the unity
of the alliance
that's not the case the prime minister
says it is about unity maintaining the
decision was difficult but correct so
russia will not succeed in either
weaponizing
its energy
or dividing
our allies amongst ourselves we are
focused on being there to support
ukraine disagreement among a group of
high-profile retired generals part of a
new advisory council working to get the
right military equipment to ukraine i'm
in a broad agreement with canada's
decision it was a very tough one i'm a
slight bit i think more harsh
on the canadian government decision rick
hillier hopes this doesn't signal allies
easing pressure on russia but he's not
so sure in hindsight it may be seen as a
straw that broke the camel's back
meanwhile a new reality for europeans in
the coming months you're going to see
really high gas and electricity prices
this winter across the eu almost
guaranteed russia's next move still a
mystery abigail beeman global news
ottawa
vladimir putin is making a rare trip
abroad for face-to-face meetings with
the leaders of iran and turkey the visit
to tehran is the russian president's
first trip outside the former soviet
union since he launched february's
invasion of ukraine topping the agenda a
deal with turkey to allow the resumption
of grain and the conflict in northern
syria these meetings are also being seen
by some analysts as a sign that moscow
plans to strengthen its ties with allies
in asia in the face of western sanctions
and that is global national for this
tuesday night i'm jeff semple tonight's
your canada is the northern lights over
tobery ontario we love seeing your
canada so please keep emailing your
pictures to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you back
here again tomorrow have a great night
[Music]